el centro de México se queda seco en el
municipio de Villa Victoria en el Estado
de México decenas de personas se
enfrentan a graves complicaciones para
encontrar un bien esencial para la vida
el agua la presa que alberga esta región
al este de la capital es parte del
sistema de aguas Cutzamala una red de
presas y bombas que abastece buena parte
de líquido que se consume en Ciudad de
México
ahorita en nuestros últimos años ha sido
más complicado ya ya se carece más del
agua
sí antes no batalla mucho con el agua o
sea que haya bien abastece perfectamente
bien pero ahorita ya si ya se la batalla
más con el agua el sistema cutza mala es
una red hídrica compuesta por siete
presas distribuidas entre los estados de
Michoacán y el estado de México
aproximadamente 6 millones de personas
en la capital dependen de su
funcionamiento para abastecer sus
necesidades ya que las fuentes de agua
dentro de la ciudad No son suficientes
para el consumo de todos
que es el gran desafío llevar agua desde
fuentes externas como es esta que
importa el agua del Estado de Michoacán
Estado de México y lo lleva hacia la
zona metropolitana de la Ciudad de
México y el este y además en lo que
representa el
caudal que abastece el sistema Cutzamala
es únicamente el 25 del orden del
veinticinco por ciento
de lo que se consume en la ciudad sin
embargo a día de hoy el Cutzamala se
encuentra en sus niveles más Bajos en
sus 27 años de funcionamiento expertos
atribuyen este fenómeno a una
combinación del cambio climático la
sobrepoblación en la ciudad y la falta
de mantenimiento a su infraestructura